[Applause]
everybody in my family catches lobster
me and my sister are fourth generation
lobstermen throughout these generations
of all of us lobstering the lessons I've
learned about sustainability or if we
don't protect it now then we're not
gonna have it in the future
I'm Heather Thompson I am captain a
fishing vessel gold digger with my
sister Hillary as my sternman my
great-grandfather was a lobster man my
grandfather was a lobster man my dad is
a lobstermen my two sons a lobstermen
and my niece is a lobster then my name
is Lanie and I'm the fifth generation
lobster fishermen it's what we all do
it's really it's a physically demanding
job I mean you have to worry about the
tides bait getting your rope buoys your
traps so many things it's even hard to
fathom until you actually have to go and
do it one of the scenes my father used
to say was be somebody you know it
doesn't matter if if we were a guy or
girls on the back it's like if you want
to do it you can do it you just have to
make sure you push yourself be somebody
do it he's taught me just about
everything I know
especially the sustainability of lobster
making sure that we're protecting our
own future and my children's generation
- catch lobster we plan to do this the
rest of our lives if it allows us
lobster fishermen have been practicing
sustainable fishing for many generations
before the regulations even came into
effect we inspect every single lobster
we pull aboard if it's under sized
we throw it back and if it's over sized
we throw it back we want the resource to
be sustainable and if we take the big
ones in and harvest them then there's
not Lobster for future generations when
we pull up a lobster that has eggs on it
we take our tool and we make a little
nick in its tail we call it a v-notch it
makes a little V in the fin that means
you throw it back because it's an egg
bearing female and that's important for
the future sustainability of blobstore
population our future is worth more than
that we're really appreciative of the
job the fishermen do day in and day out
it's a tough job and we establish
face-to-face meetings with them so we
can understand their business who their
family is and what their challenges and
opportunities are and helps us to keep
the resource vibrant for future years
and it helps them meet our needs and get
the highest quality seafood if we don't
take care of our future then nobody else
well it's our kids future my grandfather
always told me to be somebody it means
to like work hard and do your best at
whatever you do in the name of my boat
is be somebody
for these fifty years throughout these
generations of all of us lobstering my
great-grandfather practiced
sustainability of lobsters he protected
the lobsters he threw back to ensure
that my generation and my children's
generation would be able to to catch
lobster when a lobster is put on
somebody's plate and brought to them and
they look at it I want them to think of
how much of a tradition and how much
time and effort and thought went into
this this catch it's a lot of
generations a lot of learning a lot of
hard work a lot of time that went into
that
you
[Music]